[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos de los diálogos que se llevan
a cabo en viena para tratar de salvar el
acuerdo nuclear de 2015 el gobierno
iraní aseguró que no es ni optimista ni
pesimista ante la reunión aunque
calificó el encuentro de un nuevo
capítulo en el camino correcto saludamos
en este momento a césar jaramillo
integrante de la campaña internacional
para abolir las armas nucleares gracias
señor jaramillo por estar aquí con
nosotros en francés 24 la posición de
irán es clara retiro de las sanciones
por parte de eeuu y dejan el
enriquecimiento de uranio y la posición
de eeuu también es clara retiro gradual
de estas sanciones cuando irán cumpla
con lo establecido en el pacto como
llegarán a un acuerdo con estas
posiciones
así es muchas gracias por la invitación
lo primero que hay que resaltar es que
hay optimismo moderado en este momento
por parte de observadores de ese tema en
la comunidad internacional de que al
menos las partes reconocen cuál es el
punto de llegada se busca salvar el
acuerdo nuclear con irán entonces esa
parte es bastante positiva pero como
usted bien lo ha dicho él
y me oyó ahora del asunto tiene que ver
con el orden de los pasos con la
secuencia a seguir quién da el primer
paso entonces allá hay un poco de
orgullo diplomático por parte de eeuu
por parte de irán y ambos esperan que
sea el otro quien dé el primer paso
debemos recordar que fueron los eeuu
quienes se retiraron unilateralmente el
tratado bajo la administración de donald
trump en el 2018 pero ya bajo el
gobierno de dubai venga ya hay algo
esperanza de que si puede haber un
avance con irán así es y es que también
el portavoz iraní señaló que si en el
encuentro queda demostrada que la
voluntad de estados unidos de regresar a
este pacto nuclear es sincera eso podría
ser según este funcionario una buena
señal para su implementación final en
las próximas semanas esto podría suceder
luego de estas conversaciones que
podemos esperar de estos diálogos
también parece que si las partes se
hayan demorado bastante en moderar las
expectativas de la comunidad
internacional en decir que no hay
soluciones mágicas que en un día
mismo cuando cuando inician estos
diálogos en viena no va a haber no va a
haber un gran avance se supone pero a mí
me da a mí me parece que las condiciones
están dadas para que si se ve el avance
lo que usted menciona de la voluntad
política es muy importante en términos
diplomáticos y me parece que las
autoridades de la delegación de irán va
a estar muy atenta a cómo percibe la
actitud de los eeuu sin embargo no van a
verse cara a cara hoy se van a ver la
delegación de irán con los con las otras
partes del acuerdo del acuerdo nuclear y
por aparte la declaración de los eeuu
también se va a encontrar con los con
las otras partes de del acuerdo nuclear
con irán pero el hecho mismo de que se
estén encontrando hoy de que haya esos
diálogos ésta está generando bastante
optimismo y esperamos que se pueda que
se puede sortear los obstáculos que hay
en este momento así es también la
república islámica ha negado en
reiteradas oportunidades el ingreso al
país y también a sus plantas nucleares
de los integrantes de la organización
internacional de la
energía atómica de ser fructíferas todas
estas conversaciones las autoridades
iraníes le pueden volver a permitir el
ingreso a estos funcionarios por
supuesto no sólo no sólo podrían
permitirle el acceso sino que para
volver a estar en cumplimiento con los
parámetros del acuerdo tienen que
permitir el acceso irrestricto de las
autoridades de la agencia internacional
de energía atómica el segundo los puntos
fundamentales y yo puedo decir con toda
tranquilidad de que si en este paso si
estás en esta concesión por parte de
irán los eeuu nuevo banalidad no van a
aliviar las sanciones entonces yo creo
que todas las partes entienden cuáles
son los pasos a seguir pero de nuevo la
parte difícil en ese momento es quien da
el primer paso pero con voluntad
política se debe poder sortear esto y
rápidamente a su parecer quien lo podría
dar quien sea quien se ve más dispuesto
a dar este tan difícil primer paso
pues en el aspecto de quien lo debería
dar yo creo que debe ser los eeuu porque
fueron quienes bajo la administración de
down trap tomaron tomaron la decisión
unilateral de retirarse del tratado pero
me parece que se debe aspirar algo de
simultaneidad dentro de lo posible para
que en la medida en que los eeuu alivian
las acciones las sanciones el gobierno
de irán va
volviendo a implementarlas los puntos
del tratado de los cuales se había
alejado así es estar gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros en francés y pueda
procuración de ustedes por siempre estar
con nosotros
[Música]